one two three
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so time
is never worth my time
blue
shine
these
my eyes
and i
still
sleep on the right side while the white
noise
can't leave the scene behind
could it be anything you want me to be
it so isn't meant to be
seen right
when you see yourself in a crowded room
do you think i said shiny pistol where
were you stepping
[Music]
see yourself in a crowded room
do your fingers hit your pistol when we
step in line or release the glitch
she shall sleep
[Music]
so now try
to hold on tight tonight
[Music]
once was mine
[Music]
[Music]
how will i know you'll still
yourself in a crowded room
[Music]
see yourself in a crowded room
[Music]
the glitch
so
[Music]
i'm waiting fading and floating away
waiting and fading floating away
waiting and fading and floating away
waiting and fading
[Music]
when you see yourself in a crowded room
do you think guys it share your pistol
with will you step in line or release
that glitch can you fall asleep with a
panic switch see yourself in a crowded
room
do your fingers hit y'all your pesto
whip
step it light or release the glitch do
you think she'll sleep
[Music]
good morning